foreign
[Music]
business associates more than half the
voters told CNN they believe the
president was involved and he lied
you can't have a response to that Korean
foreign
what a job that that woman has it is her
job cringe Jean-Pierre to stand up there
and answer the questions could anyone
whatever it is that you person watching
this do right now if the key core
component of your job if your boss asked
you something about that and you just
walked away would you still have a job
and yet that is what the machine
regurgitates out to us ladles and jelly
spoons I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it is September 14 2023 we're
live streaming as always on Rumble
locals and YouTube post game show at
reubenreport.locals.com if you want to
join us and support the show we've got a
Community Q a today and we're going to
cover a couple Clips these are breaking
right now the full interview is not out
yet but my friend and colleague Megan
Kelly She interviewed Donald Trump I
think in the last day or two they're
posting the full interview on her
Channel Channel sometime later today but
a couple Clips are leaking out right now
we're going to cover a couple of those
clips contrast them with uh some
interviews that Ron DeSantis has been
doing and a bunch more but before I do
any of that this is very very important
today uh on yesterday's program
I made a point of saying that Chief
Public Health officer of Canada her name
is Teresa Tam I called her a man okay I
said that she was a trans man now the
reason that I did this
was not to be glib we thought she was a
trans man and that was because of what
Phoenix showed me here we're going to
show it to you right there this was a
tweet by Dr Simon gotick he wrote this
is Canadian Canada's Health Minister
Teresa Tam originally from Hong Kong she
may have ties to the Chinese Communist
Party under the name Tang Yang XI and
suffers from gender dysphoria so we saw
that and that's why we thought that she
was a he we have subsequently been told
that she is not a he now it's a little
unclear quite honestly but I but we
don't have full evidence of it and I'm
not above apologizing you guys know I
like a good retraction and my reputation
is on the line so I I retract that at
least half
it's a half a retraction Michael what do
you mean is she half a man half a woman
what's going on here well then uh Connor
saw this as we were doing a little
research on this this popped up that
this this woman uh Teresa Tam was in
this documentary about 10 years no it's
about 13 years ago 2010 it's called
outbreak anatomy of a plague
2010. we'd like to show you just a tiny
bite of this documentary if there are
people who are non-compliant there are
definitely laws and and public health
powers that can quarantine people in
mandatory settings
is potential you could track people put
bracelets on there
arms have police and other setups to
ensure quarantine is undertaken
[Music]
it is better to be preemptive and
precautionary and take the heat of
people thinking you might be
overreactionary get ahead of the curve
and then think about whether you've
overreacted later but it's such a
serious situation that I think decisive
early action is the key
so now regardless of whether she's a
chick with a dick a dude with a vagina
you can put all the body parts together
the point is regardless of any of those
things I want to retract the retraction
because she is evil evil evil and if you
want to see one more bananas thing
related to this woman look at this
headline this was at the height of kovid
she wants you to wear a mask while
having sex there are clubs in Chelsea
you can go to to do that but she was
talking about one of those fabric masks
anywho let's do a program people it'll
be a little Megan Kelly versus Donald
Trump it'll be DeSantis picking up some
steam and doing some combative
interviews on mainstream media which we
wanted him to do and that the anti-woke
revolution the thing that I've been
talking about for quite some time the
days of woke have to end and we have to
get to the other side of it it seemingly
is starting to happen but the machine
just ain't gonna let it end and then of
course we will get to the Q a as I
mentioned so let's start with some of
the clips of Donald Trump sitting down
with Megan Kelly because they're they're
pretty messy for Donald Trump I think I
can objectively I'm going to try to do
this as I'm going to try with that oh
our computer freaked out I'm going to
try to do this as objectively as
possible uh but these are not good for
Donald Trump so they they did a whole
bunch on covet and fauci and the
reaction to covet and all that and warp
speed here is Trump
admitting that his administration did
give fauci a presidential accommodation
kind of backtracking it at the same time
take a look for years you've been saying
that the reason you didn't fire Anthony
fauci uh was because he'd been there for
a long time that you would have taken
heat that it would have created a
firestorm quoting your words
then for the first time in May I also
said I didn't listen to him too much I'm
getting there but then in May you
started saying well he's a civil servant
so I couldn't technically the truth is
though not only did you not fire fauci
who is loathed by many many millions of
Republicans in particular but also some
Democrats by the way you made him a star
you made him a star this is the
criticism of you that you made him the
face of the White House coronavirus you
think so that he was out at every
presser that he was running heard for
the administration on covid and that you
actually give him a presidential
Commendation before he left office
wouldn't you like a do-over on that uh I
don't know who gave him the
accommodation I really don't know who
gave him the accommodations
somebody probably handed an
accommodation he probably but let me
just tell you about facci fauci was very
important in the Biden Administration
much less important if you know he
didn't want us up China he wanted to let
everyone come in from China I stopped it
I overwrote it I overrode many of the
things he did he was much less important
to me now with that old being said he's
been there for years he was respected he
lost a lot of the respect because of
covet but he was respected okay first
off I don't want to do the Monday
Morning Quarterback thing and I think
you guys know I've tried to be fair in
that everyone gets a sort of certain
leash when it comes to covet and what
those first few weeks and even let's say
a month was like but the truth is that
he did hand the reins over to fauci and
we've played it many times you've seen
it so we're not going to play it again
he was even running re-election
2020 re-election ads of him praising
fauci and fauci praising him also to
kind of pretend that you don't know that
you gave him the Commendation or someone
gave it to him on the way out it's like
Does the Buck stop with you are are you
the President also this thing I didn't
listen to him too much again you were
running ads saying how great he was and
him saying how great you were and even
in the ads fauci saying oh he didn't
stop me and he would always listen to me
etc etc uh the idea also that he didn't
fire fauci because he would have taken a
lot of heat isn't this the guy you're
fired like isn't that like that I just
thought it was a gay Trump yeah fired ah
but like he's the guy that's known for
firing people so the guy who was the
most important piece of the disaster
that became covet you were afraid to
fire him over heat that you were going
to take with the amount of heat that you
do take so none of it really kind of
works he's also the hair is looking a
little nuts like he's kind of looking a
little crazy but it can continued on
kovid uh Megan who as we talked about
earlier in the week she is having some
sort of autoimmune issue that her doctor
believes is related to the covid vaccine
so they talked a bit about mRNA covid
shots and if there's any regret related
to all that
but I have people on the other side I
don't not my side although probably
there's some on my side too they said
you saved 100 million people because I
got it done in nine months as opposed to
five years to 12 Years A lot of people
are proud of it no I'm not proud of it
I'm saying what Democrats think
Democrats I get it I mean and I'm not
I'm not somebody who denies some of the
good that the vaccines did I I lived
through that too but of course a lot of
people have been vaccine injured and
that's one of the questions those people
are mad that they were rushed through
and that they can't sue well I never
gave mandates and people have to make up
their own you know make their own
decision as far as I'm concerned now
some places had mandates very strong
mandates a largely Democrat governance
and probably some Republicans etc etc
but there were Democrats that say why
aren't you talking about that it's one
of the they really believe strongly one
said you say and this is very smart
people they said you saved a hundred
million people worldwide in 1917 you
know they it could have been as much as
a hundred it ended the first world war
because all the soldiers were dying of
of this horrible disease of 1917. you
know it actually ended the first world
war the soldiers were dying there was
one of lines they're fighting and
they're dying of this horrible disease
they said you might have saved 100
million people 50 million people why
aren't you talking about I said I'm not
talking about it I never got I think the
credit that I deserved on covet
as Brock just pointed out it sounds like
he's running to be a Democrat the
Democrats seem to really love him and
the 100 million people he saved we
checked this morning like there's no
evidence that the coven shot saved 100
million people they're just simply isn't
there any evidence for that and if
you're watching this and you're one of
those base people I'm always warned by
my friends on the right Dave don't go
too hard after Trump because the base
will turn on you if you're one of those
base people watching this right now do
you believe anything that he just said
right there and I don't know what this
has to do with the 1917 thing and this
idea that the hundred million again the
100 million I saved 100 million lives
and she says are you proud of that and
he says no I'm not proud of it so it's
like there's just so much confusion and
conflation there and all he has to do to
get out of this and he still could do it
Trump I'm giving you a tip right now all
you have to do to get out of this is
admit you were wrong about a bunch of
things a MIT you got admit you got
Bamboozled by fauci and the NIH and the
CDC and everything else but he seems
unable to do it now I get I get it and I
still on Twitter this morning when I
tweeted out some of these clips some
people said well I don't care anyway I
don't there's nothing you could say Dave
no I
okay
okay so be it I'm still gonna tell you
what I think
uh I would like to compare what he just
said right there uh with a video that
the DeSantis team put out uh some of the
things that Trump was saying during Kobe
we did the right thing we closed the
country down could have kept it open and
I could have done what some countries
are doing I had to shut it down we did
the right thing I thought of keeping it
open and we did just the right thing we
closed it down and a group of very smart
people walk in and say sir we have to
close it
and we did the right thing they can't do
anything without the approval of the
president of the United States even the
Democrats aren't blaming me for that we
had to close it up some people wish we
never closed it down we did the right
thing we closed it it's a decision for
the president of the United States we
did the right thing we had to close it
up because nobody's ever heard of
closing down a country let alone the
United States of America we had to turn
off the airlines we had to turn off
everything
and we did the right thing a lot of
people have thought about it write it
out don't do anything just write it out
and think of it as the flu
but it's not the thing it's vicious we
basically shut down our country you know
we did the right thing we had to close
it down the president of the United
States calls the shots and we had to
close it down we did the right thing
they're not working in offices they're
not in airplanes together and we did
close up we had to close it up and we
did the right thing we closed it down we
did the right thing we closed it up we
were told we got to shut it down stop it
tell everyone to stay home
because of this horrible virus and we
did that we had to artificially close
our country we've done this right and we
we really we really have done this right
that we did the right everything we did
was right
all right look I I promise you over the
course of you know we've still got over
a year until the national election and
the first votes in the in the primary
are not going to be cast till January I
promise we're not going to drug you over
the head with these videos all the time
but in moments like these where Trump
does a somewhat combative sit down and
again Megan did an absolutely great job
I'd like to think I know a little
something about interviewing people and
sometimes you know when you're
interviewing a politician someone that
you know personally and publicly you're
trying to be respectful even when you
hear them saying things that are untrue
they're also saying a lot of things at
once you want to pick the moments when
you can push back I think she just did
an absolutely great job and again these
are only two tiny bits of the interview
the full thing will be out later and if
we find more interesting pieces later
we'll cover them tomorrow but the point
is Trump is showing no Contrition
whatsoever he's when when he talks about
warp speed he's still very proud of warp
speed he then says I saved the Democrats
say I saved 100 million people but your
own base and the and the Republicans by
and large in the country think it was
wrong so it just I get it I get it to
some people he can do no wrong but like
maybe there's a better choice maybe
there is a better choice oh there's a
guy down here in Florida and you know
what that guy did he banned mandates uh
on coveted vaccines he banned mask
mandates he banned lockdown mandates
even banned gain of function research
here in the state I think you know who
that guy is
Governor Ron DeSantis Tuesday said he's
seeking to protect Florida from what he
calls the quote biomedical Security
State announcing groups like The CDC and
Biden Administration for their pandemic
protection efforts they had a lot of
momentum they brought a lot of power to
these fights and they would have won
except for the fact
Florida said no
the Republican now offering a plan to
make permanent a slew of covid
mitigation bans enacted during a 2021
special session and set to expire in
June
if approved by lawmakers DeSantis effort
permanently restricts kovid's shot and
mask rules in schools it prevents public
and private employers from hiring and
firing based on mRNA shot status
plus it prohibits vaccine passports and
will aim to Shield Florida Physicians
from censure for speech of unpopular
medical opinions we need to lead with
this by making all of these protections
permanent in Florida statute which we
are going to do in the upcoming
legislative session you know I often say
on the show it doesn't have to be this
way like this this endless fight that
we're in the slow descent to Hell the
questioning of things that we know don't
need to be questioned anymore right it
doesn't have to be this way and guess
what in Florida it isn't that way
anymore as we've seen in the last couple
weeks as the fall has rolled in and
Whoopi has covid and Whoopi has covered
and they start and Dr Jill Biden has
coveted she's a doctor for God's sakes
as they roll out covet again and they
tell you there's another variant and
everything else every single state in
the Union except for Florida can still
be locked down can still kick you out of
uh school can still shut you out of your
business it's cetera Etc so it doesn't
have to be this way when you have proper
leadership that then does the right
thing and you have to think you have to
think okay now we're it's three years
from now and Donald Trump is President
and they bring in super covid or
whatever it is or the climate emergency
that's happening it's to the gamma rays
outside whatever it is would he get
bamboozled by the machine all over again
I think he would because he's showing no
Contrition about what he did last time
except it won't happen here in Florida
so unless you're watching this in
Florida just know that wherever you live
in the United States maybe if you're in
Sweden they're not going to lock you
down because they didn't do it last time
he used to criticize Sweden for that
right
um Trump that is
um you have to know that they can do it
to you all over again so just a couple
more Clips contrasting the sort of
confusion and lack of Contrition of
trump with with the functional
competency of DeSantis DeSantis went on
Hannity last night in New York and I
thought Kennedy asked him asked him an
excellent question because people want
that sort of more personal side of
DeSantis and I thought this was quite
good and what do you want people to know
about you that maybe they don't know
well I was the reason I'm in New York is
because I got invited to be at the 911
ceremony remembrance ceremy with some of
the 911 families so my wife and I got to
go and we're looking at the names and
they're telling stories Joe Biden was in
Hanoi yeah and then he went to Alaska or
something like that and nine I was you
know far away from it I didn't have
anyone I knew but it was a huge impact
on me that I ended up joining the
military as a result of that and I
always had put myself in a position I
could have made a lot of money but I
decided you know our country's in
Conflict uh we don't have a draft but
I'm going to step up and do whatever
part I can and so that kind of put me on
the road to service and so throughout my
career I've always put service above
self I mean I think I am the leader I am
the vehicle but ultimately it's not
about me uh it's about delivering for
the people that I represent and in this
case uh turning this country around
because this country and you and I have
talked about it it's in Decline uh we're
uh it's Jeopardy scary we're in Jeopardy
of being the first generation of
Americans who we're going to turn over
to our kids and grandkids and America
less prosperous and less free than what
we inherited and and that would be a
tragedy if we allowed that to happen so
we got to reverse the decline we need to
get America on a different path and
that's that's my mission that's why I'm
running
there's a couple great lines in there
you know just real quick to point out
when he says he could have made a lot of
money and then he went into service
after 9 11. uh he was an undergrad at
Yale he went to Harvard Law like he was
set up to make hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year at a Primo Law Firm right
out of school and instead he went and
and he enlisted and there we are with
his life right now by the way Rhonda
said this is worth a couple hundred
grand I think around 300 Grand now that
might seem like a decent amount of money
to you and it is to an awful lot of
people but in the scheme of what
politicians make if you look at
Elizabeth Warren and you look at Donald
Trump and you look at Gavin Newsom and
you look at Mitch McConnell and we look
at Nancy Pelosi I mean literally
basically all of the people you know
they all are worth 10 20 sometimes
hundreds of millions of dollars uh the
line I have put service above self it's
like when he says that I actually
believe it I believe it so I thought
that was an interesting clip and I just
want to show you one more on this
because okay fine Hannity that's
friendly territory you come talk to me
like you did last week okay that's
friendly territory one of the things
we've been saying is he needs to go into
non-friendly territory and see what
happens uh he went on Nora O'Donnell
this is this is CBS right on CBS uh and
uh they talked about the immigration
crisis take a look we're in New York
we've heard the mayor here say that this
city is about to go bankrupt because of
the migrants that are in this city you
supported sending migrants to states and
cities in the Northeast why do you
support that well we need to stop the
problem I mean so I'll shut down the
Border I will I will end these bad
policies yes we'll build the wall we'll
lean against the drug cartels I mean
part of it is the drugs pouring in or
killing tens of thousands of Americans
you also have criminal aliens coming
their sex trafficking human trust
there's a lot of stuff but just the
sheer number of people New York City is
an example you can't as a society just
have people pouring in you it taxes
Social Services Education Health Care
all these different things it's not the
way to run a country and what's happened
though is because some of the sanctuary
jurisdictions who were very high on
virtue signaling when this wasn't
affecting them have now had to
acknowledge that this is untenable for a
country to operate this way
didn't have to contort himself right is
there anything that he said did you just
hear anything that you did not think uh
that he could accomplish that he said
that he can't accomplish I'm going to
defend the Border we're going to send
the military down there like he's laying
it out and you just have to again look
at the track record what did he do in
Florida is there anything he said he was
going to do that he didn't do you know
quick point on the fentanyl thing when
we were doing our run through earlier
this morning uh Phoenix who's 22 years
old said to me that you know what do you
say five or six people that are either
struggling with or or have died
five or six people that he knows at 22
years old coming from Cali that are dead
because of fentanyl I'm 47. I don't know
anyone that was dead from fentanyl I
think I know one or two people that died
of drug overdoses that I was friendly
with in in high school but there is a
massive massive crisis happening and
we are just going to continue letting it
happen unless we elect a leader a
president in this case who's actually in
charge of the Border it's one of the few
things the president's supposed to do
and will who will do what he says he is
going to do I think we have one more uh
do we have one more to say at this there
oh yeah we do have one more of DeSantis
talking about the the school situation
which will kind of get us to the rest of
everything we're doing here and I think
most people of all different Persuasions
agree with the stand we took but I think
it's also important to say I've got
people moving into Florida in record
numbers we are the number one fastest
growing State and we are the state with
the most net domestic in migration and
that's people from all walks of life
that are coming and they're coming
because the state is successful and they
have an opportunity to get ahead most
gay people say they knew they were gay
since they were a kid
but they know most of their life they
were gay but here's the here's the
question
is what does that have to do with math
class or English class or history class
so why should they feel accepted in
schools
everyone should be accepted God it's
just so stupid watching corporate press
people even try to pretend that they're
objective but his answer of course is
perfect first off move aside the gay
thing for just a second the answer of
why people are moving to Florida people
are moving to Florida because people
care about Freedom all of the reasons
that you guys know that we cover here
all the time and then she well gay
people knew they were gay when they were
young should they be respected he's like
well again what does that have to do
with math what does that have to do with
science gay people were in school for
decades in America learning math and
science they weren't talking to their
teachers secretly about whether they
were boys or girls everyone knows that
and of course then he very calmly and
cleanly lays out everyone should be
treated with respect okay every time
I've seen Governor DeSantis and first
lady Casey DeSantis on the trail I show
the pictures of the kids they light up
like they ask how they're doing like
it's just such absolute nonsense and the
truth is everyone knows what we've done
here in Florida is Right which is why we
have those million people who have moved
here but
I do see still and and I've discussed
this with you guys many times one of my
struggles on this show is how often do
we have to pay attention to the people
that lie about everything and the thing
is I think we still do because there's
an awful lot of people still that think
we have these Evil Book bands in Florida
and Gavin Newsom right now is trying to
pin himself as the freedom Governor
which is just absolutely insane so now I
want to show you a clip we wanted to
show this a couple days ago but we were
waiting for just the perfect moment they
had a hearing in the senate about the
book Banning and what mostly about
Florida right what Florida has done with
book bags so one of our true National
Treasures Senator John Kennedy from
Louisiana he then decided to read out of
one of the books that has been banned
here in Florida and you tell me if you
think that these are words that a child
should hear in third or fourth grade
from a state employee take a look
let's take
two books that have been much discussed
um
the first one is called
all boys aren't blue
and I will quote from it
I put some lube on and got him on his
knees
and I began to slide into him from
behind
I pulled out of him and kissed him while
he masturbated
he asked me to turn over while he
slipped a condom on himself
this was my ass and I was struggling to
imagine someone inside me
he got on top and slowly inserted
himself into me
it was the worst pain I think I have
ever felt in my life
eventually I felt a mix of pleasure with
the pain
close quote all boys aren't blue
Mr secretary
what are you asking us to do
are you suggesting
that only Librarians should decide
whether the two books
that I just referenced
should be available to kids
is that what you're saying no okay tell
me what you're saying well first of all
there's this don't give me a speech tell
me what you're asking me to do with all
due respect Center and the words you
spoke are disturbing especially coming
out of your mouth is very disturbing but
I what I would also tell you that we're
not advocating for kids to report to
Senator Bookers what are you advocating
for we are advocating for
parents random parents not to have the
ability under the guise of keeping kids
safe to try and challenge the world view
of every single manner on these issues
all right first off we should have just
shown you that John Kennedy clip
completely out of context at the
beginning of the showing that I just
should have walked off the set but
that's that's one thing I'm not even
sure who that person is that he's
talking to random parents they're not
random parents they are parents who have
kids at these schools who are often on
school boards who are upset about that
so again everyone knows everyone knows
that what Ron DeSantis has done here in
Florida is right and it is the model and
the blueprint for what should be
happening across the country it has
nothing and that's why what Nora
O'Donnell is doing there at the end was
so disingenuous but the Santa's answer
was right of course everyone deserves
dignity and respect but what she was
doing was so disingenuous none of this
even though what he was describing in
that fairly graphic book was was about
gay sex it's not about gay you wouldn't
it wouldn't matter if that was a boy boy
and a girl
and the lube and the butt and all of the
stuff
you can click that and send it across
the internet it wouldn't none of it
would matter why would you want kids
reading that at school okay but if you
think that the drive of the Democrats on
the left and the establishment and the
Machine the drive on all of this is com
isn't completely out of control I got
one more for you today to show you how
absolutely insane it is Jen saki who we
have not talked about in a while who was
cringe jean-pierre's predecessor as
White House Press Secretary she then of
course you work for the White House as a
paid liar and then she gets paid even
more money to lie at the televised
mental institution known as MSNBC under
the guise of being a journalist the
farce is just so absolutely incredible
you have to admire it uh she put out
this clip yesterday talking about
abortion and how Republicans are
changing language about abortion and
listen to the way she describes the
pro-life stance this is this is
genuinely disgusting I was actually like
this is like yeah off the charts go
because they are seeking a Rebrand
in the words of Indiana Senator Todd
young pro baby Pro baby okay I hate to
break it to you but if you call broccoli
candy it's still just broccoli if you
tie a really nice bow around a lump of
coal it is still cool under there I mean
she's vile like I don't even know how to
describe that this has nothing to do
with what your feelings on abortion are
pro-life is pro baby the pro-life
movement probably should have called it
pro-baby from the beginning I mean this
is a lesson that they should have
learned from the leftists a long time
ago who control language at a much
better capacity than people on the right
do but pro-life you are pro the baby
being born we can have all the arguments
about six weeks 15 weeks the the
difference between the power of the
state and individual choice and the
health of the mother and rape and incest
we can do all of that but pro-life
obviously is pro-baby and and then that
she goes out of her way you have to
understand these people are handed
scripts I have not handed a script we
have we have clips that we play on the
show and I tell you what like what I
think right we discuss it a little bit
beforehand that's it okay but she is
handed a script and they purposely wrote
in there to compare a baby to a lump of
coal like they are just absolutely
terrible so guys the point of all of
this today whether I'm criticizing Trump
or sake or whatever or the media or
anything else the stakes are high this
is what we are up against and we have to
choose our leader wisely the leader the
president in this case is not going to
be the White Knight that will save us
all
but it might be someone who could lead
us in the right direction and if we
don't find someone who can lead us in
the right direction we could end up like
far more authoritarian States like China
for example do you know what's going on
in China
in China for example
God this is going to happen here I think
too although maybe people will fight it
if a traffic camera catches you
jaywalking in China digital ID system
has you has your blood now has your
genetic code has your photograph it can
identify how you walk so even if you
can't see a face you can be picked up by
gate it will convict you of jaywalking
and take money out of your bank account
with no intermediating Judiciary at all
and show a picture of you to the people
in the neighborhood so they know that
you have jaywalked and reduce your
social credit score and if your social
credit score Falls below a certain level
then you can't you can't buy drinks from
a vending machine you can't play video
games you can't go on a train you can't
get out of your 15-minute City all
that's already in place in China
is that a stark enough warning like that
is literally happening in China right
now China is a highly authoritarian
State and we clearly are heading in that
direction and unless you me and
everybody else decides we are going to
put people in office who are going to
fight for our freedoms and the ideas
that America was founded upon we will
end up there too so it is up to you my
friends it really is so once again
Choose Wisely and on that note let's
move to a
reubenreport.locals.com community q a
we'll try to get one or two in on the
fly if you want to throw in a question
uh right now here we go Beach Bum says
if the Dems replace Biden for the
upcoming election at what point do you
think they will do it we're getting
close and won't they have to also launch
a whole story to explain why Kamala
won't then be the candidate in his place
yeah look this is why you have to admire
the evil of the machine because they
always figure out a way they always
figure out way to do the tricks right in
front of us and we all just fall for it
again and then we often say thank you
sir may I have another my guess I mean I
said it the day that Biden was installed
as president I said I did not think he
was going to have a second term I
thought he would either physically break
down or mentally break down or the
scandals or something I still stand by
that I do not think he will be sworn in
as the next president of the United
States now with the impeachment inquiry
as I said yesterday it's not that he is
going to be impeached they will never
get the Senate to do it but you might
just shine enough light on it that
enough people now start waking up not
just the people online who have paid
attention to the laptop and all of that
stuff but now more and more people will
pay attention because mainstream it will
be harder for them to ignore it because
there's an impeachment going on even
though yesterday the White House
literally sent out a memo to mainstream
media Outlets to tell them basically to
ignore the story yes that's true Google
it
um I think enough people could wake up
to it that they'll sort of be like all
right people know he's breaking down
cognitively now there's a scandal or
what do we do as you point out Beach mom
the point the the issue that they have
is nobody likes Kamala nobody likes
Kamala my guess is they are going to try
to figure out a way to make this Gavin
Newsom and and the fact that I even say
that is so I think he is probably the
most putrid disgusting soulless person
in the United States I don't know how to
describe him in any other fashion he
would do anything for power and
he is the very definition of the sort of
sociopath on that quest for power so I
think they have a look we're a year plus
off the election right it's November of
next year so we're you know roughly 13
plus months away they have to figure out
some way to Biden will basically say
they'll say okay you know it's what it's
going to be is Obama Obama is going to
say Joe's lost the step we all see it
that'll open the floodgates they'll push
Biden out somehow that's my guess and
then they will have to figure out a
trick where maybe it's that Kamala
becomes president temporarily because
Democrats don't want to be seen as the
ones that push the black woman out she
becomes president temporarily and then
she gets pressure enough from the DNC
where she's just like uh you know I've
decided this isn't best for me and my
family we brought in Gavin as VP so you
know like I don't know I don't know
exactly I'd love to know what more of
you think like let's lay out all the
options over the next year and see who
was right in the end uh Ben says hey
Dave last night I took my dad to the
best burger spot in my hometown the
Thurman Cafe in Columbus Ohio what is
the best burger you've ever had and what
city and restaurant was it from oh that
is a great great question what is the
best burger I've ever had I mean I'm
making a pretty freaking great burger
these days but I will not say it is my
burger I'll give you one that's a little
bit it might this might sound a little
generic but you can probably find one
hopefully somewhere close to where you
live and I'm not saying in and out in
and out is pretty damn good but I'm not
certainly not say that's the best burger
uh if you've got a Hillstone in your
area anywhere near you Hillstone is also
known as Houston's some some parts of
the country uh their chain how can you
find out how many locations of Hillstone
slash Houston's are there in America
give me a number they make a really
freaking great they ground the beef
right there pickles like all the stuff
on the side their fries are great they
just make a great burger juicy delicious
we'll get a number on how many uh
Hillstone slash Houston 44 there are 44
locations in America I'm trying to think
like you know where I had a great burger
this wasn't too long ago
if you go uh can you find out one more
thing for it I'm a lot on the Fly here
when I did the event with DeSantis in
Reno about a month ago or whatever it
was no now it's like three months ago we
went to I think it's the oldest bar in
Nevada
there was a burger truck outside I had a
barbecue burger and that was so freaking
amazing there's no way we're gonna find
the name of that that truck but
Genoa bar in Saloon was the name of the
bar and the truck was sitting outside if
you're ever outside of Reno oh man it
was awesome and what a great scene that
place was like just people dancing in
the middle of the day everybody freaking
drunk and buying shots for each other we
had a blast uh Mitchell says how is your
America can be saved barometer reading
these days well that's a great question
as a follow-up to the show we did today
I think we have a chance it does not
have to be like this look I live in a
place here in Florida that that is is
protected in the best possible way look
could the federal government tank the
freaking economy could they come after
Florida in every which way yes do I feel
safer here like so on the micro level of
like how Americans can live yes you
might live in a place in Montana that is
more protected you might live in a
certain place in Texas that is more
protected like South Dakota et cetera et
cetera like you might have Idaho okay
fine
the grand project is struggling and we
all know it's struggling and it does not
have to struggle imagine if DeSantis was
president now I get it the left would be
apoplectic the media would lie about him
like the game would continue but we
could bring in functional people imagine
the amount of of good decent uh citizens
that he could bring in that were that
were effective in whatever their their
area of expertise was and we could
really fix the system I think he could
protect the Border I think he could do
some of the draining of something I
don't think Trump can do it anymore and
I certainly don't think Biden or the
Democrats can do it or want to do it
right but there is a way out so I would
say on a micro level it like for my life
here I'm very bullish on on what life
can be and for the country I think
there's a chance and we just have to
decide if we want to take that shot or
not
Casey says any updates on your garden
Casey I'm glad you asked that question
because just yesterday uh I started
doing a little Googling because we we've
had a nice little garden out here mostly
tomato plants which are very very hard
to grow in Florida especially in the
summer the heat the humidity tomato
plants need kind of a breeze to get
through and they need a little bit of a
cooler temperature so we were growing
some great tomatoes sort of end the
spring it's been it's been tough the
last couple months so I want to refresh
the entire freaking thing stay tuned and
I will uh post some pictures we're going
to get some lettuces out there and some
peppers and and a bunch more Ben says
did you see Bill Maher has decided to
break with sag and bring back his show
yeah I wanted to cover this today it
didn't quite fit in the show so we'll
try to get to it maybe tomorrow or next
week so as you guys know there is a
writer strike happening in Hollywood
nobody really cares right the late night
shows are not on production on virtually
every show has completely shut down and
Bill Maher announced yesterday I think
he did it on Twitter he put out a
statement I read the whole thing
basically saying look I sympathize with
the writers I am a writer on my own show
I'm not happy about doing this but it is
time to get back to work he said you
know I have many people on my show who
are I think they call it below the line
uh which are you know the the key grips
the sound guys all of the people behind
the scenes that are not writers these
people are now out of work because of
the writers strike he said that he
helped some of them financially but it's
time to get back to work so they're
going to go back to work he's not going
to do a monologue because you need the
writers for that I think they're going
to just do more of a of a panel show and
I guess he'll do he'll do interviews but
I think it's time to get back to work
right like he he loves doing that that's
what he wants to do and it's right and
then the thing is I think the writers
have made a massive mistake here
um people are distracted in other ways
whether it's freaking video games or
it's actually going outside old school
throwing a ball around or whatever
people care about I don't think people
have really missed Hollywood I don't
think people have missed the shows I
think there's a long Bank of shows that
you can watch on Hulu or Netflix or
whatever else I don't see anyone
anywhere I mean no one's even talking
about it so I think the writers could be
in a lot of trouble here Margaret says
do you think George Soros could have a
specific strategy to mess with the
Republican presidential primary by
funding vivec
is he funding vivec I don't know about
George Soros funding Vivek I do know
that that he was a Soros fellow which I
I guess at one point he denied taking
money from the Soros Fellowship then he
said he did take the money because he
needed it I think some of the Vex
flip-flops on this sort of thing have
hurt himself but I have no evidence that
he's taking money from Soros right now
but again the only candidate on either
side who has done anything anti-sorrows
truly I mean Donald Trump has even taken
money from Soros in the past the only
one is Ron DeSantis who fired two Soros
back the AIDS here in Florida Veronica
says as you celebrate one year with dads
what's surprised you the most uh that
you enjoy what has been something that's
a challenge that you didn't feel
prepared for uh well Luke is about to be
one Justin is one now
um
you know I just well first I really love
it like I love it in a way that I did
not know I was gonna love it at first I
was like a little I think the first like
month or two and they're just so
precious and Tiny like I was a little
like wow what are we doing what what are
these little humans in our house like
What's Happening Here
and then over especially the last couple
months like they're laughing more and
funny and like funny and like bizarre
and you can watch their brains like come
to life and like one of the fun things
that we do is so the way we do dinner
with them is we put them in their high
chairs and David was big on this it's
kind of messy but we have a dog to clean
up most of the aftermath Clyde uh we
just put the food in front of them so we
break up you know like little bits of
meat or chicken or fruit and vegetables
or potatoes and we just put it all in
front of them and let them figure it out
or some yogurt and stuff and by the end
they are just freaking covered like you
would not like they look like they're in
costumes like it's just dripping every
but they love it and they're feeding
each other and throwing it and Clyde's
going crazy and then we go you know then
it's bath time right after that and just
wipe it all off and do it again like
just those little things and the fact
that you know I'm pretty busy during the
day but like after the show today I
think I have about an hour break before
my next thing I go in there I play with
them for a while well sometimes I have
to change my outfit for my next thing
because I get you know spit up on or
whatever it might be but it's uh it also
just like it orders your life in a way
that can't be explained properly or at
least that I can't quite explain
probably uh Michelle says hey Dave any
comment on Rick Grinnell calling to
Santos a homophobe on Megan Kelly's show
last week not that you're obligated to
do so just curious uh well first off I
like Rick a lot Rick is a friend I did
not hear that or see that Rhonda Santos
is not a homophobe of and also the
phrase a phobe a phobia is an irrational
fear I don't think that Ron DeSantis has
an irrational fear of gay people there
are hundreds of thousands if not
billions of gay people that are living
and flourishing here in Florida go to
South Beach see what's going on okay I
don't go to South Beach I don't know
what they're doing but I know they're
there
um it's just it's just not true so I
would have to watch that clip in context
to fully see it but you know look Rick
is a trump guy I respect that
um is what it is so he's he's fighting
the fight just like I'm fighting the
fight so uh Danielle says if you could
interview any living person and give
them truth serum right before sitting
down who would you choose well look the
easy answer on this one is Trump because
if you even watch the stuff that we
played earlier with Megan it's like it's
hard to tell what Trump believes at this
point like does he really believe the
vaccine was good does he believe that
the Santos was bad like I would love to
know if you just like really could just
get like
unadulterated truth out of the guy what
would he tell you
I don't know I think if you gave to
Santa's truth serum you'd get pretty
much the same thing and that's why it's
kind of refreshing that's why when I
discuss this stuff I don't have to twist
myself every which way to defend the
santis if tomorrow 10 Clips come out
where he just absolutely lied about a
whole bunch of stuff
I would have a problem right I would
have to address it and whatever but so
Trump just because of the level of lying
now it's out of control but that's like
an easy version of it who else would I
want to know really the truth from
guess like like Bill and Hillary maybe
about the Epstein stuff like some I
don't even want to know what the truth
is there kind of but like maybe oh but
then I end up dead
I retract this we're live streaming
today that's a damn shame it was nice
knowing all of you Benjamin says uh what
advice would you give Governor DeSantis
right now to put the fork in former
president Trump can we move past Maga
well look there's a long way to go
because you still have to get the base
which is why I'm trying to do the show
in the most respectful way for those of
you that are that base thing right
because it's not about it's not about
destroying Maga the idea of make America
great again get rid of the the crazy
leftists fight for freedom and
capitalism and all of those things make
sure that the the swamp doesn't overtake
us all again like they did during cobit
those are all sort of good Maga related
things I think clearly DeSantis is a
better uh Communicator he's a better
vessel to get us to the other side of
this thing than Trump is so I just think
as I keep telling everybody you know I'm
on I'm on a group text with my my
Florida friends I got about 10 Florida
friends some of whom come on this show
and we're always talking about you know
what's going on and what's going on in
the state and what's going on in the
country and I always say over and over
again when people start getting worried
and looking at the polls and oh my God
Trump's at 50 percent
patience guys patience Tortoise and the
hair where everyone just take a break
take a breath we got a long time to go
and and if we deserve it and if we fight
for what's right then we will get a good
outcome here maybe we don't deserve it
maybe not enough of us will fight I
think there's a chance uh Jeff says what
are you most looking forward to before
the year ends wow uh what am I most
looking forward to before the year you
know one thing that I'm really really
looking forward to actually is Jordan
Peterson is doing his Arc conference in
London at the end of uh October it's uh
what does Arc stand for responsible
citizenship what is the a uh not
Americans for responsible citizenship
um we'll get what the acronym means in a
second but it's basically a conference
like a five-day conference in London to
completely counter the world economic
Forum so the world economic Forum of
course you guys know Klaus Schwab and
all these guys it's this top-down
globalist version of what the future
should be Jordan is putting this uh
together it's the alliance for
responsible citizenship thank you
um he's putting this together to give a
bottom-up counter to that how can we fix
the world's problems without destroying
economies without without you know
saying everything has to be green so we
shut off fossil fuels and thus kill
people who are going to die from coal uh
from being cold right like there's so
many ways to do these things so he's
getting media people he's getting
philosophers he's getting lawyers and
politicians and it's this five-day
conference in London so I'll be in
London uh I think from October 28th to
around the November 2nd or 3rd I haven't
been in London for probably about four
years so I'm looking forward uh to going
back there and just like all my cast of
characters are going to be there and
hopefully hopefully Jordan and and all
of us together can present an
alternative to this globalist movement
that seems to be taking over the West
right now so that would be the big one I
would suppose for the rest of the year
uh memo says do you think or don't you
think the House Republicans or do doing
are just doing the dirty work for the
Dems by impeaching Biden they want him
gone more than we do running against him
would be Child's Play compared to a
Michelle Gavin ticket yeah I've sort of
alluded to this over the last couple
days you got to be careful what you ask
for here because Biden
it's a known quantity right we know he's
compromised we know he's not great we
know he's not going to campaign we know
there's no energy there he somehow one
last time but like we know what it is if
the whole thing flips and then suddenly
it's Gavin and Kamala or Kamala and
Gavin or gay Peter like then the whole
game has been changed and when the whole
game's been changed you just don't know
what comes out on the other side of that
so I think as I said it's like there's
some I see why McCarthy did it shine a
light on the freaking thing so people
pay attention to it but you got to be
careful what you ask for and I will see
which way it plays Shelley says have you
taken your boys to put their feet in the
grass most kids are quite amused the
first time they feel it yes we have done
that we take them out to the yard we've
tried to get their hands dirty I was
mentioning the tomato plants before so
try to just get them dirty see make sure
they're not allergic to anything trying
to make sure they don't eat too much
dirt we've taken them to the one of my
favorite things to do actually is we've
taken them to the petting zoo a couple
of times and they get to see the cows
and the donkeys and the chicken and the
rabbits and the pigs and all that stuff
and that's that's totally fun obviously
we don't put them in the pen with them
but yeah try to get their feet there
it's important because you know then
they get good bacteria also you don't
want to keep a kid just kind of
quarantined let's say locked in a room
where they're never gonna get sick
they're never going to get any germs so
we've we've tried to do a little of that
Barry says when did the retailers like
Starbucks take out chains Etc begin with
tips robbery asking for a tip and
suggesting 10 20
Etc when you pay merely getting a cup of
coffee or your Chinese takeout yeah this
is a new thing where it's everywhere
even when I go to the the farmers market
that we go to here on Sunday it's like I
get a cup of coffee as you're pointing
out and they're like how much do you
want to tip 10 20 30 40 50 you want to
double this thing just because I handed
you the cup of coffee it's like that's
what your job is a tip is really
resigned Dennis Breakers talks about
this a bunch a tip is designed for a job
well done uh I am a generous Tipper I I
love when I go to a restaurant
I I really mean this I love it if you
get a great waiter at a restaurant and
it's few and far between these days like
the service industry especially post
covid has really struggled but if you
get a great waiter bartender or whatever
I love over tipping because it's like oh
you showed up you did your job right you
were present you knew the menu you told
me about a cool tequila whatever it
might be and there's so few of those
people I would say it's way way way
better in Miami than it was in LA in La
service and the funny thing is in La
service used to be great because La was
the place that all the actors came right
so all the struggling actors became
bartenders and waiters and they would
work hard and smile and be entertaining
because they would always think oh this
guy that I'm waiting on might be a
talent agent or an executive or
something and then something happened I
mean coven ruined everything in La these
people became utterly miserable I don't
blame a lot of them by the way because
they had to wear masks while the people
eating didn't because that's science and
all that stuff so la just became
absolutely terrible in service and New
York's become terrible in Service Miami
is still pretty good that might also
have to do with a bit of our Latin
culture here where there's just like
more there's just like more warmth to
the people or something but yes the
thing about tipping just because you
just did your job like when guy you know
we just redid the studio and we had
people delivering things and I always
tried to tip the guys they're lifting
all this heavy and like all that
kind of thing that's that's one thing
especially it's hot here in the summer
these guys come in they're dripping they
don't make a lot of money like that but
like oh you uh you are the guy you know
who put the ice cream in the thing that
you were supposed to I have to also too
yeah I get it I get it uh that's it for
today
I hope if you're the base of the drum
people you don't hate me I'm just
telling you what I think and for
everybody else well I love all of you
truly I really do tomorrow speaking of
people I love we've got the uh Friday
Round Table Extravaganza uh two
Floridians Josh Hammer from Newsweek and
Carol Markowitz from the New York Post
will be joining me uh we leave you with
a cold Clues Corrine Jean-Pierre Hunter
Biden you'll get it just a moment and
we'll see on the other side for the post
game show reubenreport.locals.com adios
foreign
why would Republicans do this
[Music]